what's up reject nation Greg Alva here
with first-time guest JT JT e who you
might have seen on screen junkies
champion in the Schmo down he is an
awesome awesome homie of mine where
actual friends now not funny
we've actually hung out let's not get
crazy shut up tell everyone we're
friends first of all reject nation cool
little nickname for your group there I
feel like that was me like in high
school my friends I dabbled in two
reactions I do a little bit more than I
used to you guys are kind of the king of
the reactions so I'm happy at court
Tyrone Tyrone is a kid
Tyrone is great man a little more depth
here maybe we'll see we'll see
JT e black panther deleted scene was at
least it's called married couple fight
I'm surprised we're not releasing this
in theaters just to make like another
fight let's check this out and then
we'll talk about it use your headphones
I'll ecology you efficient your
professional your preferred and so
here's you've seen that dollars
incredible as a director would know just
didn't work inside of it it's not of the
confines more work you know never heard
talked about the scene between the
characters quarry in a copy you know any
more making us news the attention but
for the audience to really realize that
the quarry and what congressman and wife
said I had it kind of had a
confrontation I like argue me about
where Wakanda was gonna go after two
challahs death um you know in the in
their in the tribal council rules this
is after they all I like when directors
interest on our key we're in Daniel ku
you know but it's just didn't marking it
in the film I'm really excited about
like supposed to see it anyway
you didn't seem to have a problem when
he was thrown from before it was the
challenge he lost if you bring back did
he hurt him
did your dog in from I don't care
crossbow from us he made my mother a
para 30 years there's been no justice I
decide what to bring him back
Wow this mistake a give you n-no take it
to the CIA bring him here to us I should
really like the scene why'd they take
this out pacing maybe huh but if this is
what you would have me leave the
daughter for to bring our children into
this world where they become callous yes
children will be leaders of a truly free
well what is it time you country where
we have to hide anything that makes us
great
it'll be war and death
but in the end it'll be beautiful
oh my god
this is like an important scene yeah it
is going a little long though so I kind
of get it
Wow
first of all halfway through that fight
she should have yelled do that I find
this scene very fascinating because one
of my minor minor complaints of black
panther was specifically what copy an
issue I had was why didn't anyone ever
address to him that they had claw and
kill monger broke him out there's so
much information that they could have
given him where he could have sided with
Black Panther and this addresses his
perspective this addresses his point of
view that clears up a lot for me movie
has a certain speed to it yeah so I'm
curious like where this would have been
in the movie cuz if this was coming at a
point where things were kind of
escalating yeah I believe this after he
died so a shorter version of the scene
would have worked for me yeah fight they
had and then it kind of died out yeah
they would have cut it like right after
the initial fight I think it could have
worked it would have been too long I
agree with that I think that it would
slow down the movie and I already felt
like you know after the always lost
moments at all I felt like the dark
night of the soul coming goes on a
little too long for my taste
specifically for Maccabiah I thought
this fixes a lot for me for a coy way
it's not necessary when she decides to
still serve kill monger it's already so
established within her character loyalty
this only adds to that the moment two
were coy is standing against in that big
moment where she says like for Wakanda I
know this scene would have added more
effect there that's a very memorable
scene but I think this would hadded a
little extra punch if it was in there I
agree and also we didn't really get what
happened after the big battle like do
they make up they like I'm the bend he
didn't show up in the video work where
was he that was the big question right
now we're copy again I get why he cut it
I do think he goes along I think it
would've gave a little boring backstory
there's a lot going on this movie
there's a lot and I feel like I got what
was gone this guy brought him cloth oh
yeah something that T'Challa couldn't do
and he wanted revenge I think above
anything else this scene what's
interesting is you get a different
emotional side to these two a lot of
times I see these deleted scenes and I'm
like yeah make sense yeah this was an
actual village scene where I was
thinking this actually does add to the
movie I get wise
in the movie but I think it does add
elements to all the other scenes that
take place after it - and does clear up
some stuff so yeah I enjoyed it I mean I
agree there's times where you see delete
scenes you like totally understand why
they cut this I watch this when I go
they liked it and they only cut it for
probably flow in time exactly exactly
but it does that it does that it does
that well hey that was really cool the
scene are you gonna get the blu-ray I've
seen their blu-ray collection showgirls
every Rocky movie after one it's a fun
but yeah I will pick up the 4k blu-ray
soon absolutely we could watch it on
your projector yes where you are
constantly playing The Adventures of
Pluto Nash I can't tell you how bad it
is you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification about the
subscribe buttons mean nothing more
importantly check out jte movie thinks
on his youtube channel where he does
reactions and movie reviews as well it
is a fantastic channel with major sex
appeal so go check it out as soon as you
can hold on go on tell more about legit
sex appear check us out on before